When we first met.
Oh yeah.
We were young and wild.
Oh yeah, I think it was at a bar.
It was.
Restaurant.
Yes, Chez Jay.
Chez Jay in Santa Monica.
With Luke Wilson.
With a Wilson.
And you were doing "Alex and Emma" together, I think.
Oh, that's what it was.
And I was dating him.
Yeah, you were.
I think he was also dating
other people.
Other people.
Yeah, totally, it was an open relationship, we were young.
I've been there with a Wilson too.
(laughter)
It's so funny because when you're young,
you're like, it's low stakes, we're just young,
we're having fun, we're all playing, actors, hanging out.
You're not taking it all so seriously, and it was fun.
And we had the best time.
We did, we had the best time.
But I remember sitting on, just because you, I mean,
you been in the spotlight for your whole life.
And as a little girl, looking at actresses,
Drew was one of them where you're like, you know,
I mean, for any young girl my age,
it was like Drew Barrymore.
And so I remember sitting and like,
I used to get people saying like,
oh, you kind of look like Drew Barrymore.
Oh what a a compliment to me, I'll take that one.
Yeah, which is why I ended up doing you on SNL as well.
Oh my God
They were like
Can you do Drew Barrymore?
I was like, I don't think so.
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
I was so little, I'm such a baby.
Oh you were, you were, so you nailed it by the way.
It is magical, it's your mouth.
That's what I realized is that when your mouth,
also, you have so much expression in your face, you know?
And so I was like, if I just like commit to the expression
and you do that thing where you get really excited.
It's so funny, I was doing the movie "Fever Pitch"
with Jimmy Fallon
and the Farrelly brothers were directing it.
And they loved us to surprise each other
and improv and get unique reactions.
So obviously they had hubbub down the side and kibitz,
and Jimmy came back and he was like,
you know, I love how crooked your mouth is,
the side of your face.
And he made sort of an, you know,
probably I'm sure what's an inappropriate joke,
it's a Farrelly brothers movie.
And I had never realized.
And that was the moment that changed my life
and held up a mirror to the fact that-
That you have a little...
I never noticed it before Jimmy Fallon
said it to me on the set of "Fever Pitch.
And now I see it.
Well, it's kind of like, you know,
my mom has the same thing,
you know, when she smiles,
she has her like big, beautiful crooked smile.
And I think it's just like,
I think it's just the most amazing quirk
(upbeat music)